c'est un très bon roman que la chambre
des officiers de marc dugain dont il ne
faut surtout pas manquer la réédition
dans la collection de poche pocket
douloureux son sujet et évite le
mélodrame et centre tout au contraire
dans la dignité
car c'est des gueules cassées qu'il
s'agit ici de ces grands blessés de la
face pendant la première guerre mondiale
le narrateur adrien part pour le fonds
est en chemin s'unit fugitivement à
clémence
on
touché à peine arrivé il est évacué vers
l'hôpital du val-de-grâce torture
physique innommable souffrance morale
inhumaine
adrien au sens propre n'a plus de visage
au reste il n'y a pas de miroir au mur
dans sa chambre à ses côtés d'autres
victimes
b nanterre éveil qui deviendront les
amis de toute une vie laquelle pourtant
reprend malgré les mutilations avec ses
désirs tous ses désirs
le trio voudra quitter l'hôpital
arpenter les champs elysées où leur
apparence terrorise croiser des femmes
au bordel retrouver leur amour
d'autrefois
tous trois finiront par se marier et
part assuré leur descendance et quand en
1940 ils croiseront d'autres blessés
d'une autre guerre
ils entreprendront tout naturellement de
leur apprendre la gaieté